the long-awaited season 11 has finally
been released and like so many seasons
before it there have been a number of
hints and clues snuck in there even
after just the first Target there are so
many questions
in this video I'd like to discuss some
of these including the castle sediment
the hunter drones and related Intel and
the season 11 trailer
[Music]
firstly let's talk about the castle
sediment it has been years since the
settlement was first attacked by the
true Sons using a weaponized version of
dc-62 but to be fair in game it's only
been a few months
there have been rumors around the castle
sediment but I haven't paid much
attention as there wasn't anything
official to back it up
my first thoughts when we were directed
there in game there is more to the story
we don't need another settlement we've
been fine without it so far however it
does paint the picture that perhaps the
jtf and civilians are doing a little
better in DC than we've been led to
believe up until now I've always felt
the existing settlements and even the
White House were barely holding on at
this point but if they are able to
divert this much Manpower and other
resources perhaps things aren't as Grim
as they've seemed over the last few
months in game
however like I just said I believe there
is more to the settlement
when running around and checking out the
compound you can see a lot of work going
on comms being set up electricity
foundations for buildings farming spots
plus a number of jtf who look like
they're just over this and probably
should have just called in sick
the underground area seems to have been
locked off but there is another way down
there heading onto the street you can
find this entranceway that leads you
directly under the settlement there are
no guards or anything but there are
doors to be opened it still works in the
same way as the settlement as in you
cannot use weapons Etc except there
really is nothing down there I've been
through it a number of times and there's
nothing except for a few unmarked
civilians
but back up in the main section you can
find a crafting table and a
recalibration station this immediately
struck me as odd as there only so many
locations that have this and the other
two DC settlements certainly don't
from everything I'm seeing here the area
feels incomplete not just because
they're currently rebuilding the place
but that there is far more planned for
the area in the near future
I feel like a lot of the assets here are
just placeholders for the next few
months where eventually this place will
be of far greater significance to the
story and I'll expand on this idea
further a little later in the video
[Music]
when first jumping into season 11 we
meet Manny for the usual Target brief
but then we are immediately sent to the
castle to meet Wally
there has been an increase of Hunter
drone activity in DC and she has managed
to hack into a couple of them revealing
some Intel
now this is obviously the way that the
main comms are going to be acquired this
season but it's good to hear the hunters
are still being featured in the story
anyway the first two comms were received
through the sentel follows a similar
path of the Intel received in the chunks
Manhunt
got proud of DC I spoke with Cal
yesterday and he has assured me that the
rumors are just rumors the report out of
St Louis a complete fabrication nothing
to worry about
even if it were true it's an anomaly not
a trend
nothing for you to worry about what
about supplies going through the area we
have alternate routes
there is no danger of shortages if
that's what you're worried about hey you
talk to chunks I have
I assure you there are no shortages and
we have more than enough to sustain us
we are in this for the Long Haul
the first one covers something I
discussed in the chunks Manhunt video
I'll have a link to this in the top
right but essentially Stoke pipe is
asking if these rumors are true based on
the recruited novel they are 100 True
yet for some reason Natalia or perhaps
McManus is denying it
merely
a hypothetical question okay
hypothetically
what would happen to a mortar operator
if they were to use a launcher that had
previously housed a dirty bomb Too Many
Factors to consider
exposure time amount of radioactive
material amount of transfer
kind of particulate it wouldn't be
instantly fatal of course not
we're exposed to radiation every day by
the time you're showing symptoms of
radiation poisoning it's generally too
late thank you chunks why are you asking
no reason
I just like to be prepared for all
scenarios
if you're worried about exposure at the
plant you should start taking iodine to
protect your thyroid that's a very
useful information
this to me shows that Natalya doesn't
believe what McManus is saying to her
about the events in St Louis
or maybe her and McManus are just trying
to cover this up from their crew for
some reason
what's more interesting about this piece
of Intel is what chunks said at the end
there about taking iodine to help
protect the thyroid
the reason this is interesting is
because of something that Wally said
after completing the chunks Manhunt
guess we should start looking for
natural sources of iodine just in case
should probably start eating more fish
and seaweed from Mario's exhibits at the
aquarium
took me a few seconds to click when I
first heard this to begin with I thought
this was an unknown name that would
become more important over the course of
this Manhunt as they don't tend to give
names of characters unless there is some
sort of significance to this story going
forward
but some of you may remember this name
come up in one of the classified
assignments that came out in year one
this particular one was called Central
Aquarium
you could be forgiven for forgetting
what this was all about and it certainly
had me looking through the others for a
bit of a refresher but long story short
we were there to rescue Mari Singh and a
number of other civilians at the
aquarium that was being taken over by
hyenas but the rescue wasn't really the
significant part
I'm not going to play all of the comms
as this could be a standalone video on
its own but the Intel from this
assignment showed the interaction
between Murray and her colleagues they
were short on supplies and worried about
what they were going to do going forward
when it came to feeding the animals
under their care
everything was locked down they weren't
able to get trucks in and they couldn't
simply take the animals away
they contemplated feeding the smaller
fish to the large ones and mammals but
this would only be a temporary solution
Murray eventually acknowledged that the
city is full of hungry people and that
food is running out perhaps the best
solution was to honor the animals and
provide them as food for the hungry
population rather than just let the
animals starve to death
but it wasn't just all about killing off
the larger animals and feeding them to
the people
the aquarium has a sustainable fishing
program they have the facilities to
provide a communal fishery a source of
food for the starving civilians
this was certainly a big deal at the
time a sustainable source of food but
with everything else going on in year
one it was easy to have forgotten this
however with the threat of radiation
along with the growing need for food The
Mention Of Maori beneficiary is no
coincidence
she and her aquarium are something that
we're gonna have to fight for going
forward
I don't usually do this but I'm going to
play the trailer and discuss what I
think could be important going forward
we got used to winning
to defeating our enemies
or turning them to our cause Schaefer is
still in a coma so I don't believe we'll
be seeing anything from him this season
I could be wrong here he may make an
appearance later but I don't think this
will be the case this Manhunt
[Music]
but now they have their own Alliance
led by Sokolova
and if the Mastermind of the Black Tusk
is coming to Washington
it will be to eliminate the division
that's why she needs stovepipe
they don't care about the cost this
agent Watch scene is something I pointed
out on Twitter and Instagram it shows
that there are more than just trophies
for the hunters that they are drawing
Intel from them but what they already
seem to know everything about each agent
especially given that Calvin McManus as
the Secretary of Homeland Security has
had all of this information around the
division agents so what information are
they Gathering somewhat off topic I'm
seriously considering setting up my
recording studio like this I feel it
would really put me in the zone
only who wins and finally we have the
White House going dark
to me at least this symbolizes an attack
or at the very least the DC base of
operations is being targeted and brought
to its knees
maybe this is the end of Schaefer due to
the power supply being cut I don't think
so though or at least I hope not there
is a reason they've kept him alive in
the story for this long
but I think this could be the answer to
all of my questions around the castle
sediment
is probably a bit of a stretch but
that's never held me back before I think
the White House is finally going to come
under attack I've been cushioning this
for quite a while
the black tusks certainly have the
overwhelming Manpower and equipment to
do this
up until the castle sediment being
restored the White House appears to have
been run by a skeleton crew as the jtf
numbers have dropped so low
perhaps them sending so many people to
rebuilding the castle settlement is the
reason it's finally being attacked
I don't know but whatever happens I
think the castle is going to be our new
base of operations even if just
temporarily while recapturing the White
House
it's still very early on in the season
11 Manhunt and I suspect a lot of my
questions will be answered and
speculations disproved but let me know
in the comments what are your thoughts
around what you've seen so far
personally I'm loving some of the new
gear that's coming out and I need to
update a few of my builds
I expect this season being the last
season of year four we'll go out with a
bang and I'm ready for every moment of
it I hope you've enjoyed this video
thank you very much for watching an
extremes malice extremely remedia
[Music]
[Applause]